for years elon musk has been pitching a
world filled with fully autonomous
vehicles that get us from one place to
another
without any human interaction to this
day
elon musk and tesla have been pushing
forward full force
and they have not been deterred
whatsoever by the noise around them
however
the same cannot be said about the
several companies that aspire to compete
against tesla in the robo-taxi market
gm shut down their robo taxi program
maven last year
uber sold of their robo taxi division to
aurora at the end of 2020
and toyota well they never really
entered the space in the first place
even apple is shifting their focus apple
was originally
all about developing luxury robo taxis
but more recent rumors suggest that
apple is now focused on building a
personal vehicle
instead this isn't to say that these
companies are giving up on autonomy
itself by any means
rather they're just shifting away from
robo taxis specifically
this pessimistic view is not only common
among several companies
but also many countries for instance the
former transport minister of singapore
stated quote
we are not in a rush to be the first
adopter i look forward to a larger scale
adoption of av technology in singapore
but i think this will not be in the near
future meanwhile
india has tried to ban self-driving cars
in order to protect jobs
on this channel we always cover the
optimistic future filled with
self-driving cars and the people on mars
so let's take a look at the other side
why are so many companies pulling back
on robo taxis one of the biggest
criticisms of setting up a robo taxi
network
is that most people don't want to rely
on a ride healing service
companies like uber and lyft have been
extremely successful at generating large
revenues
and attracting large audiences but this
is still only a fraction of the
automobile industry
we don't exactly know how many total
miles are driven by rideshare on an
annual basis
but we can estimate this based on the
revenues of top right share services
taking a look at uber's historical
revenue graph their revenue repeated
13.444 billion dollars per year
the average cost of a variety of service
per mile is 1.86 cents
and considering that uber takes a 30 cut
of this revenue
they get approximately 55 cents per mile
even if we assume that all of the
revenue that uber gets is from rideshare
this only comes out to a total of about
25 billion miles
in 2019 it was estimated that uber
controlled about 37.2 percent of the
global ride healing market
meaning that the entire right-hand
market accounts for about 67 billion
miles per year
that's no doubt a massive amount but at
the same time
it's basically nothing in comparison to
the overall automotive industry
the federal highway administration
estimates that in 2018
drivers in just the u.s alone put in a
mind-boggling 3.225
trillion miles we don't have a statistic
for global annual mileage
but i think we can safely assume that
it's well over 10 trillion miles
that means that the global right-hand
market only accounts for a mere zero
point six hundred percent of the total
global mileage
if that with that being said the average
person
clearly does not prefer using a
ride-hailing service or for just owning
their own car
or using some other mode of
transportation of course
one of the biggest barriers for
traditional ride healing services is the
cost of the human driver
without a human driver the cost per mile
would plummet
using tesla's revenue projections for
their autonomous cars the business
journals estimates that tesla will
charge about 65 cents per mile
that's ironically just about a 65
reduction from what radio services are
charging today
over the long term it is expected that
tesla may be able to get this cost down
to as low as 25 cents per mile
but we likely won't be seeing anything
lower than that
this has often been cited as a turning
point for people giving up their cars
and relying on robo taxis but how much
does this even save
well the average car costs between 35
cents and 65 cents per mile over the
lifetime of the car
so until robo taxis start to cost less
than 35 cents per mile
there won't be any financial incentive
to not owning a car
it should be noted though that you won't
have to deal with repairs or entrance or
inspections or any of that
while you may save some hassle you won't
actually be saving any money till robo
taxis are dirt cheap
even if robo taxis end up costing just
25 cents per mile
i'm not sure if most people would switch
a dirt cheap car only costs 35 cents per
mile
so you're only saving 10 cents per mile
given that the average american drives
500 miles per year this would save them
approximately 1
350 per year or about 3.70
per day mathematically the robo taxi
would be the better choice
however several studies actually suggest
that people don't care
one survey of 1200 us consumers found
that 89
of consumers prefer to own their own car
over ride sharing
and that actually makes perfect sense
personally
i would never give up my car even though
i don't use it 99
of the time in my opinion the
convenience of having my own car is
simply too high
and considering the statistic i suspect
that most of you guys feel
the same way the thing is for the vast
majority of us
owning a car isn't based on efficiency
or effectiveness
rather it's based on convenience in fact
the same survey found that 93.5
of people viewed car ownership as a
convenience only six point five percent
viewed it as a hassle or a chore
considering this
it's very unlikely that we'll see a mass
exodus from car ownership
moreover as robot taxes become cheaper
so will the cost of car ownership
most people don't have an electric car
yet but once the purchase price of
electric cars are comparable to gas
counterparts
the cost of car ownership will just go
down even more making it even less
desirable to give up car ownership
many companies are starting to realize
this and are subsequently giving up
their pursuit of the robo-taxi market
this isn't to say that tesla and other
companies who are still pursuing the
market can't go to millions of robot
taxis
or even tens of millions of robot taxis
but
we likely won't be seeing hundreds of
millions of robot taxes followed by a
radical addition of car
ownership anyways another major reason
that companies are giving up on robo
taxis is the length of development
the general consensus is that
self-driving development has been
chugging along quite smoothly
most leading companies are already 80
done with self-driving development
but the last 20 is by far the hardest
and the longest
as the 80 20 rule states 80 results can
be accounted for by just 20
of the work meanwhile the last 20
percent of results require the remaining
eighty percent of work
so though it may seem like we're really
close to completing self-driving
development
there's actually quite a bit of
development left a forbes article
suggests that the first eighty percent
is a result of forty years of
technological development
and advancement so the last 20 will also
take 40 years meaning that we won't see
fully autonomous cars until 2060.
i'm not quite sure it will take that
long but it is true that full autonomy
is deceptively close
something else to consider is that
shifting robo taxis will require
significantly more regulatory approval
as well as legal responsibility as long
as there's a steering wheel and a person
sitting behind it
even if a car is 100 autonomous
automakers can transfer the
responsibility to the driver
this way they won't have to worry about
crashes or insurance or any of that
and that brings me on to the next major
reason that many companies are giving up
on robo taxi development
which is that for many companies it
simply makes more sense to just license
the technology if it does turn out to be
a massive market
robo-taxi development is not cheap by
any means it costs billions
upon billions of dollars in the past
tesla has gone extremely close to
bankruptcy
and though that was due to a production
issue they likely would have a lot more
wiggle room if they weren't spending so
heavily on autonomy research and
development
fortunately it worked out for tesla but
this is not a journey that any company
really wants to go through
uber for instance is already losing 67
billion
per year and this was the case even
before the pandemic
considering this it makes little sense
to lose billions more in the hope of
developing robo taxis
if tesla or some other company does end
up developing fully autonomous cars
uber can likely just license the
technology from these companies
they would be giving up a portion of
their profit margin but
that's way better than having a company
go bankrupt trying to develop robo taxis
as for toyota there's some rumors that
tesla and toyota may be partnering on an
upcoming suv
toyota would of course manufacture the
suv and tesla would provide a
self-driving technology to be put
in the car however this rumor is quite
weak and has little evidence to back the
claim
nonetheless this may very well be what
toyota ends up doing
considering that they haven't really
worked on robo taxis too much
something else to consider is that
toyota and general motors are
established automakers
they're good at making cars and selling
them for a profit they've never tried a
company on taxi model
and it's not clear if they would
actually be successful in this realm
meanwhile elon musk is ecstatic to give
this new industry a try
and potentially even stop selling
consumer cars if things work out
so from the perspective of these legacy
automakers it may be a case of them
letting tesla take the robo-taxi market
that way legacy automakers won't have to
compete against tesla in the consumer
car market
and they can stick to what they're good
at producing and selling cars
at the end of the day some companies
have shifted their focus away from the
robo-taxi market
and others have completely exited the
autonomy scene itself
this may seem counterintuitive as tesla
is still pushing really hard for fully
autonomous robo taxis
however this actually does make sense
from the perspective of these companies
the truth is just because robo taxes are
cheaper doesn't mean that people will
completely ditch car ownership by any
means
and given the financial state of some of
these companies it simply doesn't make
sense to take the risk
for more established companies it simply
makes more sense to focus on what
they're already good at
so why mess up what you've already got
by entering a brand new industry
do you guys think that backing out from
robo taxis was the right choice
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys appreciate seeing the
perspective of the other side
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one